and the secret source is to take
complicated subjects okay like taks the
software architecture and devops and
other Ai and other fields and teach them
in the most accurate handson way
possible this is our source basically
because when you're taking the the best
people best instructors with the with
the the most hands-on
experience and giving them the students
that that have the possib possibility to
learn these materials who have the
correct background and experience and
then it's win-win for
everyone for the employees for the
instructors for the companies that
companies that's sending the
instructors and this is our secret
Source because we take the right people
we give them the right subjects in the
most ER sufficient way possible with the
correct instructors with the background
and the experience and then everyone
[Music]
winning Eddie rubinov welcome to the
Maas experiment in 20 minute laders I'm
really excited to have you here H
joining me um really excited to just
dive into your world and dive into your
own experiment and your on hypothesis
thank you so much for being here thank
you thank you Michael how's it going
it's going fantastic and um I'm you know
Eddie let's just dive right into it you
know what is it about experts that gets
you really excited wow I think that
basically is the the the understanding
doing something that's changing people's
life ER and and we see it on a daily
basis because when you see ER our
students graduates finding the next exp
position learning new stuff that makes
them the best version of their
self and and and the ending of every uh
course that we are doing here ER every
program and the feedbacks and the
recommendations that we
get something that you can
buy and and basically it's the feeling
that you changed people's ER life you
gave them knowledge and as as you know
knowledge
absolutely so let's take a step back
then you're you're talking about the
world of upskilling and training people
to to become more proficient either in
their existing existing ecosystems or
new or new ecosystems what what's
happening in your eyes today that's a
driver for the need for people to
upskill to gain new skills and to become
experts okay let's let's take for for
example the the AI world now
if you're a developer and you and you
want to be an AI developer you have only
few ways to do it you can learn
online you can take uder others other
platforms or you can learn from someone
who is doing it right now who is
managing AI developers who knows how to
do it correctly and you can learn from
his experience their experience and to
do it in and and to do it in the best
way is possible and that's why we're
working with with the employees from the
biggest companies out there because they
are Paving the the way for others and
can you talk a little bit about the
changing of the need over time so I
think people have always considered that
it's important to upskill and to improve
on our on our skills but you know a 100
years ago probably or 200 years ago
probably more so people studied
something they became really proficient
in it and then they did it for 50 years
and then they retired today that's not
not the case anymore so so what is
happening today exactly this is this is
not the case anymore my parents worked
in the same place for the same company
for 30 40
years ER and now nowadays we see that
every two three four years people are
are switching ER positions companies in
in in uh tech companies and
outside um
and now in
nowadays when the tech is evolving
really quickly we had a lot of
revolutions and then now we see the AI
and before the cloud and the the covid
in the middle um and we see a lot of
changes in this area in this Fields so
we so you you can stay in the same place
race for too long unless you'll be
redundant and you have to learn always
and and always learn and learn and learn
and there are
no there are
no big Platforms in which you can deep
dive into a subject into something
that's evolving all the time and and to
be the best in it you have to take ER
classes and learn from those who are
doing it hands on every day managing
teams um learn and gaining experience
making the mistakes and learning from
from these M
mistakes and in general the demand for
upskilling right now especially in the
tech in Tech is huge because there are a
lot of people that working in Tech and
when they are and and and they always
always learning and that's in in from
our experience eight years doing it
thousands and thousands of students we
see that the demand is always always in
Rising and and the companies
also look on these people these
employees that learn all the time and
give and and understand the benefits of
learning all the time and gaining the
the most relevant skills and learning
the most relevant tools and Implement
Implement them in their current current
day-to-day
mhm what so tell me a little bit about
the the actual experience in the product
what what is the secret sauce of of what
you're doing the secr basically and the
secret source is to take complicated
subjects okay like architect software
architecture and devops and other Ai and
other fields and teach them in the most
accurate handson way possible this is
our Source basically because when you're
taking the the best people best
instructors with the with the the most
hands on
experience and uh giving them the
students that that have the possib
possibility to learn these materials who
have the correct background and
experience and then it's win-win for
everyone for the employees for the
instructors for the companies that
companies that sending these
tles and this is our secret Source
because we take take the right people we
give them the right subjects with in the
most uh sufficient way possible with the
correct instructors with the background
and the experience and then everyone are
winning and what what did you find
really gets people to engage so I'm I'm
I've always been really curious when it
comes to these platforms of upskilling
and getting people to both build the
right courage and build the right
momentum and put in the hours and the
time what what enables them to really to
really work on on on be dedicated to it
is it is it mainly the motivation that
they have for for making that transition
or do you find that there's ways in
which you can promote that that sort of
experience of of being really dedicated
look we're talking about people with
families with kids with a lot of
responsibilities then they are doing it
after
work um so basically is the the the
motivation the main motivation is is
really to be the best version of
yourself as you as you can be because
they know and they understand that
knowledge is power especially in these
areas and when you have the correct
knowledge you can um influence your
employees your company your clients and
and and and it drives them because now
people want to be the best they can be
abely
absolutely tell me a little bit about
your work so you know the the
organization and the formats you've it
looks like
you've dedicated time and energy also in
specializing in different in different
worlds and different parts of the tech
industry and you have different
specializations in those right exactly I
started this company eight years ago
while will can you takech for big gaming
company um and uh the Bic thing thing
that I saw is that there are no people
there no there is no way to learn the
most advanced ER skills and
tools um in the class with from the
instuctors that are working in in their
daytoday as the leaders in in the fields
that they are
teaching and uh basically started with
with classes for companies B2B basically
I took instructors friends friends of
mine that worked with me together ER who
um who gained this experience while
working and together we build a
courses in which we we companies big
companies and and then after a few
months and several years we also opened
it for b2c for uh for private clients
that wanted to learn these skills also
and we we have several under the experts
Group Company we have few
divisions it's product experts devop
experts it's Global lb experts which is
uh which we teaching in Europe and the
us right now doing it for eight years
five last years only this ER work from
my experience I worked almost 10 years
in tech companies with huge huge tech
companies um thousands and thousands of
students a lot of
H every month every month is you're
starting from scratch you need to I have
almost 20 salespersons that working here
a lot of operations
marketing instructors as I said before
almost 40 instructors that are working
here from the biggest companies out
there from Microsoft and meta and the
the biggest names that you can
imagine um in general well almost 80
people here and a year and a half ago we
started in Europe and half a year ago we
started in the US we see big success
also there H the company is bootle from
the
beginning I'm the 100% the owner of the
company um now we're working on opening
a branch in
London and uh in the in the US in New
York a lot of every day is different
know it's exciting I'm really excited to
get up every every morning go to work
and because I don't I I know how how do
how how would start the the day I
definitely don't know how how the day
will end I love it I mean that's a I
think that that's the art of of
Entrepreneurship right I me this is why
we do what we do we we start we we just
don't know how the day will end and
it'll it can it can be a thousand
different ways and and what's beautiful
I think is that we can we can impact it
I mean we based on our our reaction and
our energy and our optimism being you
know in the leadership positions H we
get to influence how the day ends not
just for us but How It Ends for you for
80 people which I think is just is just
awesome it's amazing you know I I
learned the computer science okay in the
big university I don't have experience
in marketing or business business or
sales I didn't have anything I started
started from scratch and along the way
you're learning everything and you
connect you're creating more
connections um you understanding better
every subjects that all the aspects of
the of running the business um know it's
I work in tech companies Global Tech
companies but doing something on my own
that will impact people in Europe and
then in the US and I see the the huge
engagement that we see getting from our
advertising and the marketing in in all
over the the platforms from Facebook
Instagram Tik Tok basically linkon Lon
LinkedIn
sorry um R all plat all the platforms
and and we see the engagement and we see
the need there
is especially especially for developers
and the product managers and the devops
engineers who want to be the best
version of the S and and it's and it's
it's amazing because before us I think
in Israel and other person we we saw we
saw T prams but in this we didn't see
something that is so unique that you can
take so comp so complex uh subjects like
let's talk for example of soft
architecture okay how can you be a soft
architect you have for the the key is
for
50 developers you have one software
architect what's your chance to be a
software architect not so high maybe
three four five% yeah and and most of
developers want to be soft because
working as developer you have only two
options you can be at a team lead and
and and manage people and your your
other option is to be a great Tech guy
who can choose the technology that they
the company will
Implement and and and understanding this
complex
subjects and taking the stuff that you
are learning in the materials that you
are learning in the course and Implement
them and it's it's amazing because the
the challenges the developers have here
and the challenges the developers here
have in Europe or in the US are the same
because coding the same in every place
that you are working in the basics are
the same the syntax is the same um but
the Technologies and the infrastructure
and and and and everything else is and
and the decision that you have to take
it's changing from product to product
and you have
to to to think about not your next
release on your 15 releases ahead
because there's a lot
of a lot of things that you have to
consider before you make any decision
the scalability and the security and
the and which database to choose and and
with which AI tool to to use and it's a
whole world
and it's really exciting because it's
it's really exciting especially for for
those who are working in Tech in senior
positions and and understand and after
the course they see how many new tools
and knowledge they
gained and and we we have a lot of
recommendations and we have a YouTube
channel almost three million views and
people are are amazed of what the
difference between when they start and
and their position after the after the I
love it Eddie I really want to thank you
for for the time and uh I think that
having been in the industry yourself and
doing the jobs yourself and and seeing
the pro the process it takes to to learn
that but being really from a background
of computer science and then being able
to translate your learnings and and
upskilling yourself in the context of
running a business and sales and
marketing and it sounds like also the
the work that you're doing is also has
really interesting operational
challenges to making it happen and how
do you operationalize its scale and how
do you now open a branch in a different
country
and how do you take that that
operational mentality you've developed
in Israel but now translated globally
and how do you really understand the
value you're providing to the customers
and to the users also now in different
regions and and of course in Israel we
have you know people from everywhere in
the world so you already have to deal
with the cultural differences um but but
I want to wish you best of luck and it
sounds like you're making very important
impact and profound impact so I really
want to thank you for the time here and
I'll keep cheering you on from the side
thank so much for joining me thank you
very much thank you for the time thank
you
[Music]